as if it weren't bad enough that I was
forced to watch John McClane yippie kai
you Millie ate himself in the latest
diehard flick now someone let roland
emmerich make a die-hard in the Oval
Office movie mr. Emmerich is a repeat
offender with an established mo he's a
serial Oval Office abuser he had aliens
level the building an independence day
and then he led a tidal wave in golf at
in 2012 now look even a Washington
hating gold bartering militia member
would admit that this is obnoxious
overkill if you want to know how a real
pro storms our nation see the power go
back and watch the 1980 film superman to
now the Kryptonian cad general zod
splendidly portrayed by terence stamp
keeps it low key he drops through a
skyline with his superman and dispatches
all armed resistance in a tidy 45
seconds of hand-to-hand combat next Zod
lightens the mood with a joke I see that
you are practiced in worshipping things
that fly heyo then in a moment that's
had far greater impact than any
seven-figure ILM explosion Zog forces
the President of the United States to
prostrate himself on the ground man when
it comes to striking at the heart of the
American spirit less is more roland
emmerich kneel before Superman to
subscribe to the wire channel and never
miss one of my rats what's getting under
your skin make a video and let me know
everyone's got an angry nerd in them